I was totally shocked and obviously  disbelieving at first and then and then  just heartbroken for the family of the  woman who's died  um it's just so senseless uh so  unexpected  and I I was I was just my thoughts just  went straight to them especially because  of the time of year it was it's it's uh  it's awful when this thing happens at  any time of year but but just the sheer  awfulness of it is what struck me the  most the last place would be Wallace  Village which is a very settled  um good Community uh that and the police  have emphasized that the almost  arbitrary nature of the place that this  happened  um it's it's not to do with the place  and I hope that that will at least  reassure frightened constituents who who  have found themselves in the middle of  this appalling tragedy on Christmas Day